the Trump administration has handed out
half a trillion dollars to support small
businesses during the pandemic but it
turns out the tens of millions have also
ended up in the bank accounts of venture
capitalists celebrities and politicians
Caleb Maupin reports the pandemic has
had a deadly effect on the US economy
thousands of businesses have closed
their doors trump's government has
launched a payment protections program
intended to keep the economy rolling
along in these hard times sounds like a
good idea
but it's off to a bumpy start hundred
billion dollars doesn't even begin to
touch it this should have been a
trillion dollar program to begin with
scores of angry business owners claim
they were also denied and the PPP loan
while its intent was I think good it's
it's not practical for what they do many
small business owners on the losing end
the recently published lists of
companies that got payments has many
asking questions about who ended up on
the winning side now when you think of a
small business you probably think of a
community hardware store or a
family-owned restaurant not TGI Fridays
restaurant chain or Kanye West or
perhaps the Burning Man Music Festival
Robert DeNiro a Hollywood actor and
Trump critic even got a bailout for his
restaurant chain I'm gonna say one thing
Trump
many of trump's harshest critics seem to
have no shame about taking PPP money
middle seat consulting a liberal firm
utilized by the re-election campaign of
Alexandria Acacio Cortez got a decent
payout ëdí associates a company
associated with Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi's husband Paul Pelosi
received a loan of between 350 thousand
and 1 million dollars making Nancy
Pelosi's recent criticism of the program
sound just a bit hypocritical the
administration's decision to hide basic
paycheck protection program loan data is
a disturbing sign of its lack of concern
for who gets this funding how much they
receive or why and finally there's Joe
Biden he's got PPP confused with PPE
to make sure we have enough PPP those
does protective gear is are there enough
are there enough PPP's enough material
Burris my holdings his sons natural gas
firm it's got ties to Ukraine was also a
beneficiary of the program as were many
top Biden donors small businesses are
really the engines of our cities of the
prime generator of jobs and a lot of
these small businesses these mom-and-pop
businesses did not get these PPP loans
no one understands why this happened
what standards were used out of a total
of all small businesses that applied for
PPP money nationally nearly 22,000 small
businesses received a loan for under
$1,000 and more than 1,200 of those
businesses receive less than $100 with
some businesses receiving loans as low
as one dollar one of the also
interesting things is is that those that
did get the loans and those are
forgivable loans were the larger
companies not small businesses but
venture capitalist companies
billionaires political powerhouse people
whether it's Republican or Democrat
everybody is drinking from the trough of
free money US President Ronald Reagan
used to say that despite rivalries
politicians were quote all friends after
six well it seems he should have added
to that all friends when it comes to
handing out taxpayer money caleb Maupin
RT New York
you